quand on rentre dans une phase de
complexe quelque chose qui est gênant
aujourd'hui c'est que la chirurgie c'est
trop simple c'est à dire que c'est
maintenant c'est trop facile de se faire
opérer c'est trop facile de tout changer
on a juste à payer et voilà c'est fini
[Musique]
hello c'est 24 ans je suis parisienne et
j'ai été connue dans l'émission de TPMP
sur le sujet Barbie Botox donc
aujourd'hui je suis venue vous parler de
dysfonction phobie de body shining et de
harcèlement numérique alors moi j'ai
grandi dans le sud de la France dans une
famille qui était un petit peu brisée
malheureusement j'étais harcelée à
l'école pendant 7 ans donc ça a commencé
au collège et ça s'est terminé au lycée
alors en fait ce que je subissais comme
harcèlement au collège et au lycée
c'était beaucoup d'insultes sur
l'apparence physique parce que j'étais
très mince parce que j'étais plus grande
que les autres etc donc on traitait de
squelettes on disait que j'étais pas
belle on disait tout le temps que
j'étais moche au collège encore ça
allait c'était pas au collège que
c'était le pire c'est quand je suis
arrivé au lycée que c'est vraiment
devenu invivable au lycée c'était
horrible j'étais changée deux fois le
lycée parce que ça n'allait jamais
et à chaque fois ça recommençait ça
recommencer sa recommencer ça
recommencer donc j'avais très peu d'amis
et oui il y avait un acharnement qui
était qui était énorme c'était tout le
temps c'était toute la journée et
pendant pendant des années ça a duré sur
le plateau j'ai parlé d'un sujet qui
s'appelle la dysphorie et ce qui est
important de savoir c'est que moi
personnellement c'est venu de ça c'est
venu du harcèlement que j'ai subi alors
la dysmorphophobie c'est un trouble
clinique qui est prouvé qui existe c'est
un truc de la pensée c'est à dire qu'en
fait on va se focus sur le moindre
détail de notre apparence ça peut être
sur le nez sur la bouche ah et j'ai un
truc là j'ai un truc là j'ai un truc là
et en fait on va se voir complètement
différemment de ce que l'on est vraiment
ça va nous pousser à vouloir changer
tout ce que l'on est qui on est moi je
voulais changer tout ce que j'étais et
bien sûr que c'est grave bien sûr que
c'est grave les gens disent c'est pas
grave etc etc mais c'est un
dysfonctionnement mental c'était un
dysfonctionnement mental c'est vraiment
c'est quelque chose qui touche
énormément de gens et dont on ne parle
pas parce que malheureusement c'est à
vous c'est un sujet qui est tabou la
dysfonction phobie parce que parce que
forcément ça touche au physique etc donc
les gens ne pensent que c'est stupide
alors que ça n'a rien de stupide parce
que j'en suis la preuve il y a plein
d'autres jeunes qui en sont là
conséquence qui en sont victimes on peut
pas négliger ce genre de maladie parce
que ça pousse justement les gens les
jeunes aller se détruire dans des blocs
opératoires à les faire des des
opérations à aller se faire charcuter
comme je l'ai fait moi et moi ça m'a
beaucoup traumatisé ça m'a beaucoup fait
souffrir j'aurais voulu ne pas vivre ça
j'aurais voulu ne pas avoir ce problème
si j'avais pu j'aurais voulu ne pas
avoir cette cette maladie quand on
rentre dans une phase de complexe
quelque chose qui est qui est gênant
aujourd'hui c'est que la chirurgie c'est
trop simple c'est à dire que c'est
maintenant c'est trop facile de se faire
opérer c'est trop facile de tout changer
on a juste à payer et voilà c'est fini à
partir du moment où on a un complexe
évidemment on y pense toute la journée
c'est à dire que par exemple quand c'est
un complexe sur lequel on nous a
critiqué pendant des années des années
des années des années c'est rentrer dans
notre cerveau et en fait on préconise
carrément le la thérapie comportementale
et cognitive pour soigner la dysmophobie
donc qui est une maladie de complexe
intense et
infini
on préconise la thérapie comportementale
et cognitive qui est une thérapie qui
sert à défaire les schémas mentaux et
les mécanismes qu'on s'est créés dans le
cerveau au fur et à mesure de de notre
vie et d'être traumatismes qu'on a vécu
c'est le seul moyen de pouvoir guérir de
cette maladie et quand on a un complexe
moi par exemple on me
critiquait beaucoup sur mon visage on
disait que j'étais pas jolie on disait
que si on disait que ça on disait que
que j'avais pas de forme on me disait
que voilà et donc du coup forcément on
va se refaire les seins et puis après on
trouve un petit défaut on voit on voit
une fois quand on quand on voit des
photos de nous moi quand je vois des
photos de moi avec des amis par exemple
je me disais couper la photo coupée je
veux pas je veux pas voir et puis
surtout aujourd'hui avec tout ce qui est
filtre tout ce qui est fait si tu veux
tout ce qui est face app c'est tellement
facile de complexer c'est tellement
facile moi je suis victime de ça ça veut
dire que en plus d'avoir fait de la
chirurgie je suis même pas encore
contente du résultat parce que sur mes
photos je me retouche en plus donc ça
veut dire que en fait on est on n'est
jamais content et c'est ce que je dis
sur le plateau de Cyril je suis venu
avec ce message là acceptez-vous
acceptez-vous parce que de toute façon
ça ne rend pas heureux de la quête de la
perfection ça ne rend pas heureux parce
que vous ne serez jamais parfait en fait
vous ne serez jamais parfait vous pouvez
approcher un idéal de perfection mais on
aura toujours quelque chose à dire sur
vous parce que moi je pensais justement
avoir atteint cette idéale de perfection
je me disais oui bon maintenant j'ai un
petit nez maintenant j'ai une poitrine
maintenant j'ai si maintenant j'ai ça et
en fait quand j'ai vu les commentaires
personne ne disait que j'étais belle
donc en fait au final est-ce que ça sert
vraiment à quelque chose la réaction de
mes proches mais forcément ils étaient
pas très contents parce que des parents
veulent pas que leurs enfants se
se transforme se change etc parce que
forcément vos parents ils vous voient
tels que vous êtes donc
ils vont ils veulent pas que vous
fassiez de chirurgie en général les
parents sont pas d'accord avec ça en
fait le déclic que j'ai eu quand j'ai
refait mes seins ça a été vraiment je me
suis réveillé un matin ça s'est passé
comme ça je me suis réveillé maintenant
je me suis dit j'en ai marre j'ai mis de
l'argent de côté je vais refaire mes
seins je suis allé voir un chirurgien je
lui dis je vais me faire opérer la
semaine prochaine il a dit OK
une fois l'opération terminée j'étais
contente
je me suis dit enfin ce complexe est
parti enfin sauf qu'après on m'a
critique encore plus parce que les gens
me disaient oui mais du coup t'es pas
belle parce que tu es super mince et tu
as une grosse poitrine donc c'est pas
beau ça c'est un commentaire qui est
beaucoup revenu aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux qui disait oui mais elle est
complètement disproportionnée etc elle
est maigre avec des seins avec des avec
une grosse poitrine etc alors le Barbie
Botox comme le disait docteur Alain sur
le plateau c'est une injection d'acide
botulique au niveau des trapèzes et au
niveau du cou pour avoir un coup plus
élancé plus long et pour avoir des
trapèzes plus définies par rapport au
nom Barbie Botox justement Cyril m'a
demandé est-ce que tu veux ressembler à
Barbie je les ai non parce que c'est
vrai j'ai jamais voulu ressembler à
Barbie c'est pas parce que je suis
arrivée avec une perruque blonde etc
avec les yeux bleus et tout machin que
je vais ressembler à Barbie
moi mon icône c'était Charlize Theron
moi je voulais ressemble à Charlize
Theron Barbie non j'ai jamais voulu
ressembler à Barbie on a tous un idéal
de beauté on a tous des célébrités
auxquelles on veut ressembler moi
c'était sur listeron il y a d'autres
jeunes filles c'est Kim Kardashian et
d'ailleurs le Barbie Botox ça a été
connu principalement grâce à Kim
Kardashian parce que c'est elle qui a
commencé à faire le barbu botox et c'est
elle qui a commencé à l'exposé sur ses
réseaux et elle a tellement elle a une
surexposition médiatique cette femme qui
est énorme et donc du coup le Barbie
Botox c'est aussi comme ça que ça a été
connu c'est pas que par rapport au film
Barbie le Barbie Botox ça existait déjà
avant le Barbie Botox c'est pas de la
chirurgie esthétique c'est de la
médecine esthétique il faut faire la
différence entre les deux le Barbie
Botox ça dure une heure ça coûte 1000
euros
et c'est juste des injections en fait
qu'on va vous faire donc c'est de la
messe c'est la médecine esthétique ça
fait pas spécialement mal c'est pas
spécialement traumatisant en ce qui
concerne les dangers du Barbie Botox moi
au début j'étais pas spécialement au
courant c'est à dire que je me disais
j'ai déjà fait du Botox
je vois pas pourquoi comment j'ai du
bottes dans le front ou qu'on mangejecte
du Botox au niveau des trapèzes et du
coup etc ça va changer quelque chose etc
parce que le Botox je me suis jamais dit
que c'était un produit qui pouvait être
dangereux je ne savais pas le danger
dans le barilotox c'est que ça peut
créer des paralysies mais ça peut créer
des paralysies si on en fait des caisses
si on en fait trop si on s'injecte tout
le temps tout le temps tout le temps
évidemment ça peut créer des paralysies
c'est pareil pour le visage si on
s'injeque du Botox tout le temps tout le
temps tout le temps au bout d'un moment
c'est sûr qu'on va être on va être on va
avoir une sorte de paralysie faciale
c'est quelque chose que j'ai vu chez des
amis à moi qui ont fait trop de botox et
qui se sont retrouvés avec des
paralysies faciales le but c'est de ne
pas en abuser c'est tout alors c'est une
opération qui nécessite ite des
retouches parce que le bodoc c'est pas
quelque chose qui reste indéfiniment
dans le corps donc forcément oui ça
demande des retouches mais donc moi j'en
ai déjà fait une
mais j'en ferai pas j'en referai pas
alors on m'a demandé si j'avais eu plus
de contrats après cette opération j'ai
répondu que oui ce qui est la vérité
j'ai eu plus de contrats par la suite
parce que forcément comme je disais ça
change quelque chose lors des défilés ça
donne une prestance qui est différente
ça donne une allure qui est différente
donc forcément oui j'ai eu plus de
contrats après je vais pas refaire de
nouvelles opérations parce que justement
je suis pas venue sur le plateau avec un
message qui disait ne faites pas de
chirurgie ne faites pas comme moi parce
que ça ne rend pas heureux pour en
refaire après donc non je ne vais pas
refaire des cheveux elle pense qu'à son
physique etc etc mais c'est pas vrai la
dysmophobie c'est c'est un vrai trouble
clinique dont énormément de gens
souffrent et
on en parle très rarement sur les
plateaux télé et c'est pour ça que j'ai
abordé ce sujet parce que je pensais que
c'était intéressant d'en parler surtout
par rapport au message que je venais
véhiculer sur le plateau parce que je
pense qu'en fait les gens n'ont pas
compris les gens ont mes jugé parce que
les gens voient arriver une fille qui a
une perruque blanc qui est super
maquillée avec un votre Barbie Botox etc
qui dit moi j'ai fait de la chirurgie
etc donc les gens mais jugent sans
savoir en fait et commentent et disent
elle est pas belle
elle est affreuse moi j'ai vu ses
commentaires là c'était c'était vraiment
c'était difficile parce que du coup je
me suis plongée dans mon passé et je me
suis dit waouh en fait ça m'a fait un
choc et j'ai parce que le harcèlement
malheureusement en fait on garde un
stress post-traumatique de ça et moi ça
faisait des années que j'avais pas reçu
de commentaires comme ça et quand j'ai
vu les commentaires je me suis replongée
dans mon passé et je me suis dit waouh
j'ai eu vraiment du mal en fait à
process quand j'ai quand j'ai vu les
commentaires j'ai vu des commentaires
qui disait je savais pas que Barbie
avait les seins jusqu'au nombril
qu'est-ce qu'elle est moche en fait il y
a aucun détail qui est passé à la trappe
c'est-à-dire que rien n'a été laissé au
hasard dans la bouche des gens je ne
pouvais pas ne pas être critiqué sur
quelque chose c'est à dire que les gens
l'Ibis ils avaient des loupes et
regarder et il se disait alors ça je
vais lui dire ça ça je veux dire qu'en
fait j'ai même reçu des commentaires qui
disaient mais c'est même pas c'est vrai
yeux euh faux yeux faux cils fausse
bouche phone
c'est les vrais je n'ai pas mis de
lentilles pendant l'émission c'était que
des commentaires sur le physique c'était
vraiment des commentaires elle est très
laide elle est affreuse ça fait pas son
âge qu'est-ce qu'elle est stupide etc à
l'école elle est socialiste là et donc
du coup je me suis dit mais
en fait venez à ma place parler sur un
plateau à cœur ouvert d'un sujet qui est
super
compliqué à aborder sans passer pour une
idiote parce que on parle de chirurgie
donc forcément
je dis que j'ai refait mes sincères mon
nez je dis que j'ai refais si il y a
forcément en fait les gens vont dire bon
elle chirurgie blonde et galeconne alors
qu'en fait c'est pas ça du tout les gens
connaissent pas mon parcours les gens
savent pas du tout d'où je viens les
gens ne savent pas un quart de ce que
j'ai vécu et se permettre de venir juger
d'une manière qui est vraiment
mais terrible terrible ça a été partout
ça a été sur Instagram sur Youtube ça
s'arrêtait plus je recevais des messages
partout sur Instagram ou je me faisais
insulter de tous les noms etc rien n'est
passé à la trappe c'est à dire que
chaque détail était critiqué j'étais
laminée sur tout les gens n'ont pas
laissé tranquille une seconde et c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que je suis venu
sans la perruque les gens disent oui
elle a mis une perruque etc dans la
Barbie etc mais en fait ce que les jours
ne savent pas c'est que en fait je me
suis tellement ronger l'âme
avec mes problèmes avec parce que j'ai
pas j'ai pas que la dysfonction phobie
comme problème dans la vie j'ai d'autres
problèmes dont j'ai pas forcément envie
de parler les gens ne connaissent pas ma
vie les gens ne connaissent pas mon
parcours et j'ai pas forcément envie de
dire tout ce qui m'est arrivé dans la
vie mais le fait est que j'ai tellement
eu d'angoisse dans la végétament était
anxieuse j'ai tellement été victime de
stress intense que j'ai fini par perdre
mes cheveux et du coup j'ai décidé de me
raser la tête donc je me suis rasé la
tête toute seule dans ma chambre un soir
comme ça c'est pour ça que j'avais une
perruque donc les gens parce que il y
avait des commentaires qui disaient
aussi oui non mais à l'arrière vécu
cette pauvre fille pour venir parler
d'un sujet aussi futile à la télé etc il
y a des gens qui souffrent beaucoup plus
mais vous savez pas en fait ce que j'ai
vécu dans la vie vous savez pas le cœur
de la souffrance que j'ai ressenti dans
ma vie pour avoir les cheveux qui
tombent à 24 ans vous pensez pas que
c'est parce qu'il y a quelque chose
derrière
et justement en fait qui est énervant
c'est que je suis arrivée avec un
message qui n'était pas celui de aller
faire de la chirurgie en fait je suis
vraiment pas venue faire la promotion de
la chirurgie et c'est ça qui est
énervant c'est que je suis pas venu en
mode ah oui c'est super la chirurgie
allez faire de la chirurgie elle est
refaire vos seins aller refaire vos
volets voir les refaire votre nez etc je
suis venue avec le message contraire je
suis venu avec le message clair j'ai
souffert j'ai vécu ça je suis malade
donc
maladie égale conséquence et cette
conséquence est mauvaise donc ne suivez
pas mon chemin ne prenez pas exemple sur
moi car je regrette que j'ai fait
aujourd'hui alors si j'ai un conseil à
donner pour le mois de la fin
n'hésite pas de chirurgie restez tel que
vous êtes n'essayez pas de plaire à tout
le monde parce que vous allez vraiment
pas plaire à tout le monde je vous
l'assure j'en suis la preuve